et justement à saint denis le stade de
france s'est transformé en vaccinodromes
objectifs affichés injecter jusqu'à dix
mille doses antico vite chaque semaine
l'enceinte sportive a ouvert ses portes
ce matin et on constate déjà quelques
problèmes d'organisation regarder à
l'intérieur s'est bien passé et reçoit
bien les gens ils s'occupent bien mais
bon les vaccins n'étaient pas là il
fallait qu'on attende
alors quand ça arrive et ça on attendait
vraiment un bon moment et puis 20
minutes une demi heure et puis après les
vaccins il est arrivé ben c'est mal
organisé tout le monde pour noront les
blouses blanches tout ça tout le monde
tourne en rond mais c'est très mal
organisé
pascal entrées on devrait nous donner un
numéro est passé par numéro mais là les
derniers passés les premiers nous
l'attend l'organisation s'est un peu à
peu le fouillis mais sinon ça va on
attend que tu peux et après on est
enregistrée sur des ordinateurs
voilà avec la capitale et tout ça pour
de la sécu et ensuite on attend et un
médecin ou une infirmière qui avouent
chercher pour vous faire vacciner